in the clear southern sky
above the atacama desert the
easel-shaped constellation of piktor
lurks between the bright star canopus
and the vague smudge
of the large magellanic cloud
among the brighter pinpricks that define
it a faint
cool reddish star flickers
at the very edge of visibility
but its relative dimness is no obstacle
to the telescopes on the ground and
in space now trained on its feeble light
some 200 000 kilometers above the
earth's surface
the orbiting tess telescope notices a
strange
periodic flicker to the star's light
on earth we would assume such a twinkle
to be caused by distortions in the
planet's gassy atmosphere
but not so here in the vacuum of
trans-lunar space
watching this star now poetically named
the tess
object of interest toi 270
the spacecraft sees periodic dimmings
and counts one
two three objects passing in front every
3
6 and 12 days
they are exoplanets members of an alien
solar system
73 light years away
these and thousands of other distant
exoplanets are far too distant and too
dimly illuminated to be photographed
but scientists nevertheless flex their
astronomical muscles
to discover all they can about this
alien family
the sizes of the dip in starlight as
measured by the tess
spacecraft correspond to the size of the
transiting planets
and by precisely measuring the
gravitational wobble of the star itself
as the planets swing around it
astronomers can accurately estimate the
mass of each orbiting body
size and mass together give density and
with it a good idea of the exoplanet's
composition
thus from the light of the star alone we
can learn
much about its invisible companions
indeed we have characterized several
thousand exoplanets
in this way but the exoplanet family
around
toi270 presents something
of a mystery
one planet closest to the star is very
much like
earth in density and only a little
larger
[Music]
but the other two siblings seem to be of
a different breed
they are more than twice the diameter of
earth but they aren't as heavy
as we'd expect them to be if they were
made mostly of rock
[Music]
neither are they light enough to be made
mostly of gas
there must be something else at play in
the planetary mix
these are not the only mysterious
lightweight planets out there either
among the two and a half thousand
exoplanets detected by 2018
almost two-thirds of them had a density
somewhere between that
of rock and gas
looking to our own planetary neighbors
for inspiration astronomers have
suggested that these mid-size mysteries
could be miniature neptunes containing a
mixture of rock
gas and heavier icy vapours like water
and methane
but a far more tantalizing prospect is
that of rocky super earths covered
completely in water
vast global oceans completely covering
the surface and feeding thick
humid atmospheres that maintain the
planet's liquid skin
such extensive super oceans could be
havens for extraterrestrial life
and if this interpretation is correct
the thousands of planets like those
around a toi 270
could be a promising new focus for the
search for life forms
beyond earth
and close to home we have hints of what
a world of global oceans
could look like
europa one of the four largest moons in
orbit around jupiter
is skinned with an icy crust
but layers of tortured scars and cracks
in that crust
betray the fluid nature of its interior
less than 30 kilometers below the frigid
surface scientists believe
there is a vast global ocean
100 kilometers thick
a warm rocky core pumps heat and
minerals into that ocean
enough researchers believe to sustain
life
[Music]
yet limited by its size and its exile
into the cold outer solar system
europa is a pale icy imitation of the
potential glories of a true
ocean world
in picturing a warm watery planet we are
left to our imagination
and the vagaries of simulations with the
scant data we have
[Music]
if only we could travel back through
time
then just 175 million years ago
or one billion years ago or three
billion years ago
the earth itself could have lent
structure
to our imaginings
because at several points in our
planet's history our world has been
ruled by a single
global ocean a super ocean
whose unique dynamics had the power to
transform the earth
and life for millions of years
[Music]
this video is sponsored by magellan tv
the documentary streaming service
magellan is essentially a netflix for
documentaries with over 3 000
quality works spanning loads of topics
they've been a great inspiration for us
as we've plotted our journey through the
earth's history
an excellent resource to turn to to help
spark ideas
their selection of science and earth
history documentaries in particular is
great
and one example that teams well with
this video is life on
fire a series that explores the
remarkable ecosystems that can build up
around earth-shattering volcanoes
a cracking watch that gives great
insight into the history of our globe
and you can now take advantage of an
exclusive offer
30 percent off an annual membership this
gives you an entire year for less than
3.50 a month even if you've joined
magellan before
and lapsed you can simply click on the
link in the description to claim your
discounted membership today
thanks
[Music]
on the 21st of december 1872
a british navy corvette floated out of
portsmouth
creaking and swaying on a falling tide
with the wind
rippling in its sail
small warships like this one had seen
action in the napoleonic wars
but this particular vessel was not bound
for conflict
it had had its 17 guns removed and
scientific equipment
installed in their place
laboratories equipped with microscopes
sample bottles and chemicals filled the
ship's interior
a specialist dredging platform had been
constructed and nearly 300 kilometers of
hemp rope was coiled on board
in preparation for deep water operations
this was the hms challenger
the very first dedicated oceanographic
ship
which set out to fill in the blank blue
spaces
in our maps of the seas
of course challenger was not the first
to explore our vast and mysterious
oceans
its voyage had been preceded by great
expeditions by columbus
cook and the countless unnamed natives
of coastal lands
seeking to discover what lay just be on
the horizon
[Music]
but the motivation for all of these
maritime journeys had been
primarily to discover more about the
lands on the other side of the ocean
not the oceans themselves
the challenger expedition of the late
19th century was really the first
to set its sights away from the land
and instead pursue the mysteries of the
deep
[Music]
probing the open ocean and the sea floor
to learn how this gigantic
portion of our planet really worked
for three years the ship trawled earth's
many interconnected oceans
traveling the south atlantic the indian
ocean the southern sea
and south pacific before returning to
england in may
1876 the naturalists on board sampled
the water
sea floor sediments animals and plants
using trawlers nets and scoops
the sounding ropes measured the depth of
the sea floor as they traveled
revealing for the first time the shapes
of the ocean basins
and discovering one of the deepest parts
of the ocean in the western pacific
plunging to a depth of more than 11 and
a half kilometers
this vast submarine abyss is now named
the challenger deep in honor of the
little ship that found it
[Music]
challenger's discoveries were exciting
novel and revelatory
but they were by no means comprehensive
the tantalizing morsels of data the
expedition returned
gave life to the brand new science of
oceanography
which continues to make brand new
discoveries to this day
as with so much of science great
advances are made during times of
terrible conflict
and as opposing sides sought maritime
advantage during world war
ii and the following cold war we learned
more about our oceans
than ever before
today our titanic oceans cover more than
70 percent of the earth's surface
with an average depth of nearly four
kilometers the shallowest sea floor lies
on the continental shelves next to most
major land masses
but then plunges down to the flat
abyssal plains that
underlie each great ocean basin
and at their opposing edges these planes
dip even deeper
into narrow ocean trenches
the challenger deep part of the mariana
trench at the western edge of the
pacific basin
is one such hellish crevasse
[Music]
it is often said that we know more about
the surface of the moon than we do about
the depths of our ocean
this is in part true and is little
surprise given the clarity with which we
can see our dry
airless natural satellite and the
relative ease of visiting it
[Music]
for the bottom of the oceans it's a
different story
[Music]
water may seem benign pleasant and
innocuous to our eyes
but when more than 1.3 billion cubic
kilometers are pooled over the earth's
surface
it becomes one of the most potent
barriers to scientific study
we know of
[Music]
sunlight can only penetrate the top 200
meters or so
leaving 95 percent of the abyssal depths
in utter blackness we have
no hope of seeing the ocean floor from
the surface
were we to travel to these ocean plains
to traverse
them and map them as ancient
cartographers once did the land
we would be faced with another crippling
barrier
four kilometers of water above the
would-be explorer
exert a pressure some 400 times higher
than at sea level
enough to crush the air out of their
lungs and
buckle all but the strongest pressurized
craft
combined with the oppressive blackness
and freezing temperatures
this is an environment more hostile than
even
the far-flung depths of space
and so modern oceanographers must use
other tools to understand this alien
world on our own planet
instead of seeing with light they take
their inspiration from the natural world
and scan the ocean floor with sound
like hunting sperm whales and bats who
emit ultrasonic pulses
and build a picture from the returning
echoes ships on the surface of the ocean
scan the abyssal depths with sonar
[Music]
and use the echoes to map the shape of
the sea floor beneath their keels
sonar and gravity readings have helped
us map all our ocean basins
but only to a very coarse level
at just five kilometer resolution
objects as large as central park or the
entirety of gibraltar
could be missed
higher resolution scans on a 100 meter
scale
are still in progress but only about a
fifth of the oceans have been imaged to
this level
and new features are being discovered
all the time
in 2009 a four kilometer wide crater was
discovered on the atlantic sea floor
prior to the higher resolution imagery
we had no idea
it was even there
since we first dipped our toes into
oceanography some 150 years ago
our knowledge of the seas has grown
hugely
the light we have shown into our
mysterious oceans
has helped to reveal their role in our
planet's
endless geological cycle
reading the shape of the ocean floor
helps us build a picture
of those oceans evolution over
unimaginable eons
and so although they may seem quiet
static and passive
throughout our fleeting lives
reality the ocean depths are constantly
transforming
reshaping themselves and the character
of the entire planet
in turn
edward zeus enjoyed his academic life in
vienna
this elegant city with all the coffee
chocolate and home comforts and 19th
century man could hope for
was also within easy reach of the
geological marvels that so fascinated
soos
in just a few days by carriage and horse
he could ascend into the towering
alpine peaks or descend
to the mediterranean coast
comparing and cataloging the rocks he
found along the way
as professor of geology at the
university of vienna he considered it
his responsibility
to know all there was to know about his
corner of the world
and he matched his diligent observations
with carefully considered speculation
on how things came to be
seeing structures on the high mountain
peaks that seem to correspond to
submarine processes
seuss suggested that the alps had indeed
formed
at the bottom of a now lost ocean
his hypothesis of how they came to be
raised nearly five kilometers above sea
level was
unfortunately rooted in the accepted
views of the time
that the earth was cooling after its
fiery formation
contracting and therefore crumpling the
surface
rocks that had once smoothly laying at
the bottom of the ocean were buckled
upwards
shaping mountain ranges with the
remnants of seafloor sediments at their
tops
[Music]
more than a hundred years on with
information gleaned from oceanography
and global geology
we know now that this so-called
contractionism theory
is unfounded
rather our ocean basins and land
surfaces have been shaped by the
constant
cycles of plate tectonics over billions
of years
and yet soos was correct in his
assertion of a long lost ocean
whose remnants are now perched at the
top of the alps
this ancient ocean he named tethys
after the greek sea goddess who was wife
to oceanis
alongside tethys soos identified another
ancient ocean of greater more
magnificent extent
he named it panther lassa greek for all
sea long before geology entertained the
concept of continental drift or plate
tectonics
edward seuss imagined a time when the
oceans were combined into one
great all sea
a vast super ocean that covered much of
the planet
soos couldn't have known how right his
speculation
had been
[Music]
tracing the ancient history of our
oceans is not a straightforward task
while the remnants of continental crust
tend to stick around
buoyant and resistant in the face of
tectonic clashes
it is invariably the luckless oceanic
crust that meets its end
trace chemical evidence from the
planet's first few million years
tell us that water was delivered to the
planet in such a quantity
to create great pooling oceans
and we also know that plate tectonics
after a stumbling start
eventually began to create continental
and oceanic crust
with distinct chemical and geological
characteristics
but the actual geological record of
oceanic crust
the dense basaltic slabs that underlie
our abyssal plains
is shockingly shallow
[Music]
the oldest parts of the ocean floor
today are a mere 200 million years old
new data from a few isolated basins on
the eastern mediterranean suggest that
the sea floor here could be almost
340 million years old a remnant of
seuss's tethys ocean
yet either way compared to the roughly
three and a half billion year history of
plate tectonics
a few hundred million years is a
figurative drop in the ocean
ninety-five percent of ocean crust
history has been lost
[Music]
forever
[Music]
how then are we to recreate the history
and dynamics of ancient super oceans
like the oceanographers who thought
laterally to image the sea floor
geologists must use tools and proxies
to reconstruct the echoes of these long
lost
seas
some of the biggest clues that can
reveal not only the past existence of an
ocean basin
but also the dynamics of its demise are
what geologists call
a lothanus terrains
even though old cold dense oceanic crust
may be sacrificed to the mantle in plate
tectonic clashes
a memory of it remains in the unique
rock formations that grew on its surface
throughout its life
[Music]
just as a ship or a whale that drifts
into the ocean will accumulate
barnacle hitchhikers over the years so
the ocean's slabs
will accumulate geological hitchhikers
mantle plumes or ancient subduction
zones will punch through the thin
oceanic slabs below
building cone-shaped volcanic islands
like those of hawaii
or the ryuku islands south of japan
where the volcanic blisters grow close
to the ocean's surface
their slopes are colonized by light
loving life
coral reefs grow and build circular
atolls
that persist even as the volcano erodes
away
[Music]
the impassive persistence of plate
tectonics cares little
for these geological barnacles the ocean
slab continues to slide
pushed from one end and dragged under
from the other
until the new made islands teeter on the
edge of the subduction zone itself
the ocean's slab cannot escape its fate
but often these new masses of rock are
simply too large to slide under the
abutting plate
instead they are scraped off at the
boundary to pile up among the contorted
wedge of sediment
that once blanketed the sea floor
these are the alothanus terrains
entire masses of rock that formed in one
location
were transported by plate tectonics and
unceremoniously rammed into one another
[Music]
because of the chaotic nature of their
assembly these jumbled and sacked
remnants are not
easy to interpret but information
contained within the ancient
coral atolls or the magnetic compasses
from volcanic rocks
can help to build a picture of the
conveyor that brought them there
another creative approach to
reconstructing past oceanic basins
extends the science of sonar to
surprising depths
[Music]
sending sound waves through the fluid
ocean can produce an echo
that builds a picture of the sea floor
beyond our site
now geologists are sending seismic waves
merely another kind of vibration through
the upper layers of the earth
to build a picture of the structures in
the upper mantle
when oceanic crust is subducted into the
mantle we find that it doesn't
completely melt
away rather it snaps and slides
downwards
slowly through the semi-solid rock
stacking up
at the boundary between upper and lower
mantle where density changes
stop it sinking further by finding these
stacks of ocean slabs
600 kilometers beneath the ocean floor
we can begin
to rewind the tectonic conveyor and
rebuild ocean layers that are hundreds
of millions of years old
[Music]
the murky oceanic history that these
clues reveal is one of remarkable
repetition
it seems that ocean basins tend to open
and close
time and time again along the same
suture zones
the once separated continental masses
converge on one another
until the last shreds of the ancient
ocean are consumed
leaving its crumpled echoes smashed into
the ugly scar
a scar that will open up again all too
easily when the tectonic tide turns
again
in this way our modern atlantic is at
least a second generation of ocean
preceded by the iapetus between 600 and
400 million years ago
of course our greatest tool in
understanding the evolution of ancient
oceans
is in the remnants of ancient continents
ever since our water was delivered not
long after the earth's formation
geologists do not believe that the total
volume of the oceans
has changed so our abundant if
fragmentary remnants of ancient
continents and supercontinents
give us indirect information about the
oceans that surrounded them
[Music]
when continents were dispersed we can
deduce ancient oceans that separated
them
and when supercontinents assembled the
remaining 70
of the globe must have been covered by a
single
vast super ocean
the ages of the super oceans therefore
correspond with the ages of
supercontinents
and although understudied compared to
their charismatic
continental counterparts they have
nevertheless
been christened with speculative names
and so edward seuss titled the last
great super ocean
[Music]
panther lassa was the all sea that
surrounded the supercontinent of pangaea
during its 150 million year tenure
throughout the carboniferous permian
triassic
and early jurassic
[Music]
prior to pangaea the supercontinent
rodinia
saw all land masses combined into one
for several hundred million years
during the late proterozoic
but the planet was dominated by its
super ocean
neurovia since living things had not yet
colonized the land
this gigantic singular sea connected all
of life on the planet
as the history of supercontinents
becomes less clear in the distant past
so too do the assumed super oceans that
girdled them
some paleogeographers suggest the
supercontinent of kennel land reigned
about two and a half billion years ago
[Music]
and give a name to its companion super
ocean
la rova
but with few geological proxies to
characterize either land or sea so
ancient
both kenoland and larova remain
speculation
for now
so we know that at various points in our
earth's history
the surface has transformed
there have been times of continental
separation
and continental collision
similarly there have been times like now
when the oceans are fragmented by land
and times when the vast majority of the
surface has been united
in a vast singular ocean
geology can help us reconstruct the
history of these super oceans
but we must look again to oceanography
to appreciate how these monstrous seas
shaped the planet
on the hawaiian island of kuwai mount
waialeoli rises a modest 1500 metres
above the turbulent surface of the
pacific but from the summit
it is almost never possible to see the
waters below
the smooth volcanic peak is almost
permanently shrouded in thick
cloud
this lonely mountain nearly 4 000
kilometers from the nearest continent
is one of the wettest places on earth
standing alone in the center of the
largest ocean on earth today
it snags every passing cloud
precipitating a
deluge onto its steep volcanic slopes
nearly 10 meters of rain falls here
every year
it is not difficult to imagine an island
like kuwai existing some
billion years ago in an ancient super
ocean like morovia
this hemisphere spanning ocean would
have resembled the pacific in many ways
it would be composed of several immense
oceanic plates
each committed to their individual route
across the globe
driven by convection currents and the
forces of their own momentum
they grow as new material is added at
mid-ocean ridges
but creation is all but balanced by
destruction
hundreds or thousands of kilometers away
at subduction
zones where plates meet be their ocean
and continent or ocean to ocean
the clash ultimately sends one slab
plunging into the mantle
restoring the balance on the surface
mantle plumes rise from the depths of
the planet to push through the centers
of these wandering plates
creating island chains like hawaii
and the emperor sea mounts the preserve
a trace of the plate motions as the
crust moves over the hotspot
the geological processes are easy to
visualize
but in a world ruled by one ocean
conditions at the surface
become much more unfamiliar
take for example the tides
on earth today tidal ranges vary
massively around the planet as a curious
consequence of resonation between
water flowing in and out of individual
ocean basins
in some places high and low tides can be
separated by as much as 15 meters
yet in a single super ocean these tidal
resonances
are diminished as the planet turns the
mound of water pulled outwards by the
moon's gravity
could travel around the globe unhindered
and supercontinental shorelines
are unlikely to see a tidal range more
than about one meter in height
[Music]
and for rodinia this equated to a
globally small
intertidal habitat perhaps delaying the
colonization of the continental fringes
by proterozoic life
[Music]
the absence of any major barriers within
a near global ocean
also has profound implications for the
movement of air
and water currents across the planet
today our oceans circulate
via unseen currents that distribute heat
from the sun-soaked tropics to the
ice-covered poles
[Music]
but this circulation is also shaped by
the positions of continents
cool deep waters flowing north along the
east coast of africa
are stopped in their tracks by the
indian subcontinent and are forced back
south
[Music]
the eastward flowing north atlantic gulf
stream is diverted north as it hits the
european mainland
weaving between continents the ocean
currents tie the seas together
in a complex oceanic conveyor
it takes 1 000 years for water
to complete its tour
[Music]
but in a single simple super ocean
there are no obstacles to deflect and
divert the currents
we see a hint of such circulation around
antarctica today
the newly defined southern ocean is an
uninterrupted channel of water defined
by a single
immense circular current chasing its own
tail
like the mythical auroboros
[Music]
and moving 130 million cubic meters of
icy water every second
[Music]
sailors know this treacherous stretch of
ocean as the shrieking
60s thanks to the high winds and
towering waves that dominate the zonal
circulation
at 60 degrees south
[Music]
and like the southern ocean written
large super ocean
circulation is simple devolving into two
immense
circular currents called gyres
that dominate the north and south
hemispheres
the sun continually warms the tropical
oceans near the equator
and this heat attempts to equilibrate
moving towards the poles
but the spinning globe diverts it from a
straight flow
deflecting it to the right in the
northern hemisphere and the left in the
south
this happens in our modest oceans today
but in a worldwide super ocean there is
nothing to stand in the way of these
gyres
flowing towards the west in the tropics
and to the east in the polar latitudes
such constancy creates very different
conditions on opposite supercontinental
shores
on the eastern shores of mirovia cold
waters are transported from the poles
and upswell from the ocean depths these
cool fresh waters contain nutrients
dredged from the sea floor
which feed immense algal blooms and the
life forms that evolve to exploit them
[Music]
on the rodinian west coast a productive
tropical paradise
rained
but the tropical oceans today are also
the nurseries of some of the most
powerful storms on earth
[Music]
warm surface oceans evaporate and build
into towering cyclones that track
westwards
feeding and growing as they go
over the 4 000 kilometers of the north
atlantic yearly hurricanes develop and
lay waste
to the caribbean and us east coast
in a super ocean dominated by this
westward tropical flow
where storms can travel and grow for
more than twenty thousand kilometers
uninterrupted
the seasonal cyclones have the potential
to reach truly
deadly intensities
the eastern rodinian seaboard would be
raised and ravaged by howling winds
ferocious rainfall and colossal storm
surges
even hardy marine microorganisms would
find themselves battered and bruised by
the force of this immense weather
stromatolites are destroyed at a stroke
and the coastline is continually
reshaped by floods
landslides and cliff falls this
is a messy turbulent coastline where
only the hardiest
or most foolhardy choose to eke out a
living
[Music]
there is evidence from the rock and
fossil record that these super ocean
circulations
occasionally bred an even more deadly
peril
that of stagnation and asphyxiation
for periods of up to 10 million years
parts of the panthalassa
became rigidly stratified
with life-giving oxygen failing to reach
the lower levels of the great ocean
although oceanographers still aren't
sure exactly how it came about
the implications are clear
without enough oxygen throughout the
water ocean creatures
died in their droves
we may be thankful that we aren't living
through a tempestuous
and occasionally strangling super
oceanic age
and even though plate tectonics grinds
ever on
growing the atlantic and reconfiguring
the pacific
we won't see another super ocean on
earth for
200 million years at least
future projections of our continental
shifts agree that a new supercontinental
age is coming
as our current continents crash and
crumple to become pangaea
altima
[Music]
so it follows that there will be a super
ocean to girdle this new
gigantic land mass
but there is some disagreement over how
that super ocean
will be formed
some predict that the atlantic ocean
will eventually stop its eternal growth
and begin to close just as the iapetus
did before it
to address the balance the pacific will
grow ever larger
perhaps splitting into more plates to
accelerate the pace of growth from a
greater number of margins
other projections see the pacific doomed
as the atlantic opens ever wider
squeezing the ring of fire ever tighter
until it is little more than a
compressed seam of long-lost volcanoes
or perhaps both the pacific and the
atlantic will be no more
and it will be the indian and the
southern oceans that expand to dominate
the globe
however it happens the resulting super
ocean
will be a formidable sea for our
descendants to cross
and so an extraterrestrial ocean world
may seem at first glance to be a haven
for life
beyond earth but that life
must be uniquely equipped to survive on
a planet ruled by wild water
wind and weather
[Music]
you've been watching the entire history
of the earth
don't forget to like and subscribe and
check out our partner channels
history of the universe and something
incredible
i will see you next time
you